[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue pour un nouveau
débat sur tv 78 également sur radio
sensations dans le cadre du premier tour
des élections municipales débat
aujourd'hui consacré à magny les hameaux
trois listes sont déclarés en ce 8
février celle de bertrand guillon maire
sortant la liste divers gauche celles de
lionel lindemann sensibilité plutôt
centre droit la troisième liste sans
étiquette est menée par dominique
grattepain elle est encore en cours
d'élaboration aujourd'hui largement
incomplète selon ce dernier ce qui
explique son absence du débat son
absence du plateau aujourd'hui une
interview néanmoins à retrouver sur
notre site internet et en replay il
s'agit d'un ancien conseiller municipal
entre 95 et 2001 à magny les hameaux
membres de la majorité de l'ancien maire
jacques lolliot du parti socialiste
j'accueille donc deux invités en plateau
bonjour à vous deux
au cours de ce débat je vous rappelle
que le temps de parole sera chronométrée
afin d'assurer au mieux l'égalité nous
débutons le premier tour de table avec
cette question là même pour vous deux
pourquoi vous présenter à ce scrutin
pourquoi les électeurs devraient vous
choisir vous avez une minute deux
minutes maximum pour répondre et nous
allons débuter avec bertrand guillon
c'est l'autre qui a été décidé par un
tirage au sort juste avant le début de
ce débat vous êtes le maire sortant élu
depuis 2012 vous étiez parti socialiste
par le passé avant d'adhérer à
génération pourquoi les électeurs
doivent choisir cette pour cette
élection
nous avons travaillé avec une équipe
municipale avec beaucoup de dynamisme
avec la force de la diversité et puis
dans un contexte qui ait jamais vues
dans le contexte des collectivités
locales aujourd'hui avec un assèchement
des finances locales
et puis d évolution des compétences
entre l'agglomération et les
collectivités par exemple donc un
contexte assez difficile mais nous avons
agi pour avoir aujourd'hui un bilan qui
est riche en termes de services publics
à tous les habitants en termes de
d'action dans la transition écologique
en termes d'action pour le vivre
ensemble pour la solidarité pour la
participation aussi de tous les
habitants à la vie de la commune
et puis en termes aussi d'action sur les
mobilités avec saint quentin en yvelines
où avec l'ensemble des parts
nurse comme le parc naturel régional ce
bilan donc nous l'avons partager avec
les habitants
en décembre on a eu un certain nombre de
retours sur un diagnostic qui est fait
établi aujourd'hui par rapport à la
situation de notre commune et puis nous
avons travaillé sur un projet avec eux
aussi avec les habitants tout le mois de
janvier avec des ateliers citoyens et de
là nous travaillons aujourd'hui sur ce
projet qui était établie et qui va être
proposé et donc nous proposons tout
simplement aux habitants de pouvoir
continuer dans cette dynamique avec
humilité puisque tout n'avance pas
toujours aussi vite que nous voudrions
c'est le cas par exemple pour le marché
mais certaines choses avancent eux plus
vite
finalement que ce qu'on aurait imaginé
comme le pôle médical et paramédical du
buisson donc voilà on souhaite tout
simplement continuer avec avec la
dynamique que nous avons engagées lionel
lindeman vous si j'ai depuis la fin 2010
8 souvenez vous étiez présent par don
sur la liste menée par aurore bergé en
2014 aujourd'hui votre liste n'a pas
d'investiture nom n'en réclament pas en
tout cas mais vous vous revendiquez
plutôt de centre droit aujourd'hui
pourquoi les électeurs devraient vous
choisir à magny les hameaux
d'abord personnellement effectivement
j'ai de centre-droit mais sur la liste
il ya vraiment de tout donc c'est pas
c'est pas une liste exclusivement de
centre droit il ya déjà des gens du
comité local manier en marche et il ya
surtout énormément de la politique en
fait donc on est on est quand même un
peu au-delà de toutes ces considérations
là puisque ce qui est ce qui compte à
manier c'est pas vraiment les étiquettes
des uns ou des autres c'est de savoir si
le maire en place a ou pas tenu ses
engagements c'est ça qui est important
c'est pas qu'ils soient de gauche ou
qu'ils soient de
qu'ils soient de droite c'est pas c'est
pas le sujet le sujet c est ce que les
engagements qui ont été pris lors des
précédents les élections ont été tenus
et donc sur le sujet moi je suis assez
critique puisque sur la question de la
modération fiscale monsieur oui on
s'était engagés à la modération fiscale
et puis un an après il a augmenté les
impôts communaux
il s'était exilé effectivement aussi
engagé sur un marché et puis six ans
après il n'y a pas de n'y a pas de
marché par ailleurs en fait c'est le il
se présente un sixième mandat en fait ça
fait simsim mandat d'affilée qui fait
partie de la majorité municipale donc
nous on considère qu'il est nécessaire
de sortir de ce système qui est un peu
en bout de course qui tourne un peu en
rond avec une nouvelle équipe et de
nouvelles compétences
mais voilà c'est pour ça que vous êtes
candidat qu'on est quand même
aujourd'hui pour ce scrutin voilà pour
ce premier tour de table nous allons
passer aux thématiques de ce débat juste
après un premier sujet qui revient sur
quelques uns des enjeux de ce scrutin à
manille les mois à cheval sur le parc
naturel de la haute vallée de chevreuse
et l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines magny les hameaux à une double
identité rurale et urbaine une commune
de 9000 491 habitants répartis en sept
hameaux et sur 16 kilomètres carrés un
isolement géographique qui pourrait
s'améliorer grâce à l'augmentation de
lignes de bus ou le développement de
pistes cyclables pour quitter ou accéder
à magny les hameaux de route
départementale qui pose problème la 91
passant par voisins le bretonneux
rapidement combrée en heures de pointe
est source de conflit entre les deux
communes en octobre 2018 côté château
fort la 938 est tout aussi impactés a
été envisagé un temps la réouverture du
chemin vicinal 7 fermer en octobre 2000
par nicolas abou maire de montigny le
bretonneux
après la fermeture des jardins de
cocagne en 2015 la question du passé
agricole de la commune s'est posée la
ferme de bulot y est destiné dans un
premier temps à être vendus ne le sera
finalement pas saint quentin en yvelines
a donné son accord en 2010
un projet de pérennisation agricole de
formation de tourisme et d'insertion est
en cours la ferme de gomberville a été
acheté à sa propriétaire par
l'agglomération celle de la closeraie
accueillera bientôt une chaîne de
transformation de l'aisne de marché de
magny les hameaux est un souhait de
nombreux habitants marché couvert au
marché de plein vent le projet pour le
moment au point mort un appel lancé
auprès de prestataires franciliens en
2018 s'est soldée par un échec
une nouvelle tentative a été lancé
auprès des commerçants en juillet 2019
et sa place fait aussi débat et nous
reviendrons sur ces sujets au cours de
ce débat sur tv 78 et radio sensations
nous débutons par la question du
transport les déplacements qui reste
compliqué année après année au sein
d'une ville très étendue là mais aussi
pour rejoindre saint quentin en yvelines
notamment existe-t-il des solutions à
mettre en oeuvre on va commencer avec
vous gagnez ligne demain nous est à une
minute 24 de temps de parole vous avez
une vingtaine de secondes de retard par
rapport à bertrand ou lyon
existe-t-il des solutions concernant le
transport oui certainement
c'est vraiment un domaine où j'ai le
sentiment depuis 25 ans que je connais
la commune que on n'avance pas beaucoup
c'est à dire que les problématiques sont
toujours les mêmes les il n'y a pas de
bus le soir assez peu de bus le reste de
temps là il ya plus de bus le week end
finalement il est très difficile de se
déplacer dans la commune si on n'est pas
sur ma part un véhicule individuel c'est
vraiment une obligation
donc il faut effectivement mettre en
place des solutions alternatives au
niveau des pistes cyclables
il ya eu quelques progrès mais elles ne
sont toujours pas sécurisé donc c'est
assez compliqué de les utiliser
donc il faut travailler avec nos
partenaires pour quand on met en place
des pistes cyclables etc elles sont
nouvelles
pour qu'elle soit sécurisée ce qui n'a
pas été le cas sur sur le mandat en
cours
voilà donc déjà sur les mobilités douces
il faut faire beaucoup mieux que ce qui
a été fait jusqu'ici ensuite au niveau
des autobus et il faut augmenter les
fréquences
il faut en faire beaucoup plus le soir
pour que les gens aient des alternatives
après il ya d'autres
deux options il ya d'autres solutions il
faut tenir il faut qu'on travaille avec
la communauté d'agglomération qui a des
projets très ambitieux par exemple un
système de
voiture autonome sur rail alors dans un
premier temps ça ne bénéficiera pas
directement à magny-les-hameaux
mais il faut soutenir ce genre de projet
parce que
il y aura un redéploiement des bus qui
sont actuellement au niveau de la
communauté d'agglomération qui pourront
être redéployés au niveau de manière
diamant dans le domaine du covoiturage
pour l'instant à la mairie a mis en
place un formulaire en ligne sur le site
de la mairie
ça c'est typique de cette façon qu'on a
de faire à magny les hameaux au lieu de
travailler sur des plateformes qui
existent qu'elles soient privées ou
qu'elle soit au niveau de la région de
la communauté d'agglomération fait notre
propre truc dans notre coin et du coup
ça marche pas il faut absolument
s'intégrer à une si sa plateforme de
mobilité
qui existe et ça s'intégrer à ça au lieu
d'essayer dans notre coin de faire des
petites solutions qui ne marche pas un
formulaire en ligne en fait quand je
discute avec les habitants personne
n'est au courant qu'il existe donc il
faut beaucoup mieux travailler avec nos
partenaires il faut pas hésiter à
travailler avec des partenaires privés
dont c'est le métier pour mettre en
place un système performant de
covoiturage à gif-sur-yvette par exemple
il ya trente trentaine de points de
covoiturage qui sont faits en lien avec
une entreprise privée et c'est vers ça
qu'il faut qu'il faut aller voulait
dépasser les 4 minutes de temps de
parole du coup je vous interromps pour
qu'on puisse ensuite laissé répondre
bertrand guillon si vous souhaitez
répondre d'ailleurs à ce qui a été dit
par diana l'île de man est aussi vos
propositions concernant le transport si
c'est un axe important que vous jugez
important aussi concernant manière oui
je souhaite répondre parce qu'il ya un
certain nombre d'approximations et de
terreur en fait qui qui sont dites là on
a l'impression que absolument rien n'a
été fait depuis
vous dites 25 ans en termes de transport
sur la commune de magny les hameaux et
tournées sur la commune de magny les
hameaux je sais les évolutions qu'il y a
eu et encore durant ce mandat avec
l'agglomération directement liens parce
que c'est la compétence de
l'agglomération
nous avons travaillé sur l'évolution de
l'amplitude horaire des fréquences de
bus et nous travaillons avec eux aussi
sur le déploiement des pistes cyclables
avec le département également donc ces
éléments on améliore se sont améliorées
simplement il y a encore des marges de
progression notamment le week-end alors
la semaine aujourd'hui vous avez des bus
qui circulent dans la commune vers 23
heures le soir
par contre c'est vrai que le dimanche
matin il n'y a pas de bus ça fait partie
des demandes que nous avons vers
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines
mais aujourd'hui nous travaillons main
dans la main avec cette agglomération
avec aussi les autres agglomérations
puisque versailles grand parc par
rapport à la ligne de 162 et 263 travail
sur cette ligne en particulier entre
saint-rémy-les-chevreuse et versailles
chantiers et nous avons aussi travaillé
avec ces deux agglomérations sur
l'évolution des lignes express et qui
permettent aux heures de pointe d'aller
plus rapidement
vers des pôles gars il y a bien entendu
un certain nombre d'autres points vous
évoquez le covoiturage en effet il y à
des applications qui se développe depuis
récemment et qui sont aujourd'hui porté
par l'agglomération qu'il faut que nous
arrivions à faire porter par l'ensemble
du bassin de vie dans lequel nous sommes
est notamment la communauté de communes
de la haute vallée de chevreuse
également pour pouvoir avoir une vraie
synthèse finalement de mobilité qui
puisse être utile à tout le monde et
puis nous devons pouvoir travailler sur
la continuité du réseau cyclable qui se
développe d'année en année au niveau de
magny les hameaux et au vu de saint
quentin en yvelines il reste encore des
passages affaires qui sont dans le plan
vélo de saint quentin en yvelines est au
banc notamment le passage de la vallée
de la mérantaise pour pouvoir aller vers
les pôles d'activité et puis des projets
innovants il est évoqué supra ce qui
donc les navettes autonome sur sur rai
il y a aussi d'autres éléments que nous
portons avec notamment le maire de saint
rémy les chevreuse de transport par
câble
il faut que nous nous permettions
finalement tout en termes d'innovation
il ya aussi les voitures autonomes et
tout ça et travailler de concert avec 5
entendu linda et ile-de-france mobilité
j'ai d'ailleurs demandé l'organisation
d'une conférence territoriale des
mobilités qui s'est tenue avec
l'ensemble des acteurs concernés
j'y ai contribué et nous avons un
diagnostic des points noirs et des
évolutions à mener simplement il faut le
faire avec l'ensemble des acteurs tout
n'avance pas assez vite malheureusement
et il faut aussi que chaque organisme
qui a la responsabilité transport et ce
n'est pas le cas de la commune fasse son
travail
nous avons une autre thématique
environnement écologie aussi abordée a à
présent lyonnais lindemann si vous
souhaitez répondre je vous passe en tout
cas la parole puisque vous avez une
vingtaine de secondes de retard l'autre
thématique ceci l'environnement
l'écologie qui rejoint aussi cette
thématique du transport à quoi
ressemblera la ville de demain la ville
verte de demain quelles sont vos
propositions dans ce domaine je peux
d'abord à la girouette et bien sûr qu'il
a si bien raison
il ya effectivement eu quelques
améliorations mais le problème global
qui est qu'il n'y a pas d'alternative de
qualité à la voiture il reste c'est le
même depuis 25 ans je connais le
problème reste est beaucoup plus large
que juste la commune est de la
responsabilité de la commune louis la
problématique et l'éloignement de
l'habitat et de l'emploi nous y
travaillons à notre niveau au niveau de
la commune et l'agglomération y
travaillent également il y à un réseau
de développement de transports en commun
et de transports alternatifs au véhicule
particulier à faire dans tout le sud des
yvelines pour éviter les traversées
systématique de notre réseau sur notre
commune mais du réseau aussi du
mesnil-saint-denis du réseau de voisins
le bretonneux
je continue à laisser ce que j'étais en
train de dire donc encore une fois
quoi que vous disiez pour l'instant il
n'y a pas d'alternative de qualité à la
voiture et c'est un problème
d'autre part
quand vous parlez de réseau express qui
ça c'est très bien on va même il
m'arrive de le prendre quand il ya des
bouchons il est plus du tout exprès donc
c'est bien d'avoir mis des billes des
bus express mais comme si en heure de
pointe très souvent illégalement de le
prendre à cette heure notamment pour
aller à versailles chantiers ça passe
très bien ce qui me concerne quand je
reviens de versailles ça ne passe pas
forcément très bien donc
c'est donc en face ça c'est un petit un
petit progrès mais ça reste pas une
alternative intéressante par rapport à
la voiture puisque les gens qu'est ce
qui peut les inciter à prendre les
transports en commun c'est si le service
est plus intéressant que de prendre leur
véhicule particulier en l'occurrence
quand il y avait des bouchons il ya des
bouchons autant pour le bus express que
pour pour le bus d'autre part vous dites
c'est des améliorations il ya aussi des
mines de bus s'il existait et qui ont
été supprimés
donc ça a été dur et déploiement et
c'est donc effectivement il faut
vraiment changer de paradigme et il faut
que l'agglomération accélère dans le
domaine des mobilités ile-de-france
mobilité également et et nous sommes
toutes et tous au niveau de nos
collectivités des communes acteurs dans
ce domaine pour pouvoir pousser à
améliorer les mobilités et d'ailleurs
c'est un des axes forts qui doit se
poursuivre au niveau de l'agglomération
de saint quentin en yvelines
si on est d'accord voilà moi je vous si
vous êtes casse-pieds égalité parfaite
qu'on va arrêter juste sur cette
thématique est prolongée en tout cas sur
la question environnement écologie est
ce que vous avez des propositions dans
ce sens aussi normalement et l'écologie
en fait
puis il ya des gens qui s'improvisent
pas ce que c'est c'est un peu amoché
j'imagine tueur a quasiment aucun
candidat qui va passer ici qui va pas
vous dire que l'écologie c'est la
priorité et c'est on s'improvise pas
écologiste et il faut faire il faut
faire attention quand on fait des
propositions à ce que tout ça soit soit
cohérent et moi ce que je regrette
à manille c'est que il peut arriver que
par exemple il ya
il ya un projet intéressant dans le
photovoltaïque qui ceux qui démarrent au
niveau du pnr du parc naturel régional
collecter un collectif un collectif
citoyen s'est porté par parc naturel
régional tout à fait donc qui veulent
mettre enfin déployer du photo du
photovoltaïque sur sur des bâtiments
communaux et éventuellement aussi des
panneaux des panneaux chez les
particuliers
donc tout ça c'est extrêmement positif
mais au cours du mandat il ya eu par
exemple à un moment les compteurs linky
qui ont été déployés au sein de au sein
de la commune et le conseil municipal
si dans un premier temps proposé ensuite
monsieur y ont expliqué qu'ils n'étaient
pas forcément compte qu'il était pour le
pour le libre choix
mais tout ça c'est tout ça ça va
ensemble c'est à dire que si on déploie
des panneaux photovoltaïques sur sur la
commune
on passe à des électrices à une
électricité qui n'est pas constante qui
varie avec avec le temps et donc on a
besoin puisque la production varient on
a besoin que la consommation aussi de
beaucoup de beaucoup mieux la piloter la
façon de le faire c'est avec compteur
avec les comptes en ligne qui donc cette
idée d'être pour les panneaux
photovoltaïques mais pas forcément les
conséquences en déployant parmi la
population des compteurs qui permettent
de réguler la consommation
voilà c'est une des sept façons de faire
nous ne nous convient pas et donc nous
on considère qu'il faut se tourner
vous avez deux minutes d'avancé conclut
bertrand voyons monsieur lienemann va
chercher très loin en fait pour essayer
de trouver quelque chose à critiquer en
termes de en termes de transition
écologique
nous avons agi par rapport à la
rénovation énergétique de nos bâtiments
lax est très clair nous avons le
troisième bâtiment dont les groupes dont
la rénovation va commencer c'est le
gymnase auguste delaune
nous avons travaillé sur le
développement des renouvelables
on peut toujours faire plus vite mais
simplement on cherche tous les
financements et ça nous a permis de
récupérer 70 % + 2 sur 10 pensent en de
financement pour le gymnase auguste
delaune sur les sillons du financement
vous aviez d'autres styles et nous avons
travaillé sur les énergies renouvelables
et notamment de ctm aujourd'hui est
chauffée avec l'énergie bois
tout cela nous a permis de faire une
économie sur les charges de chauffage de
5% en 2019
c'est déjà une avancée nous sommes là
une des premières communes à intégrer
justement le collectif citoyen porté par
le pnr pour le déploiement sur les
équipements publics des panneaux
photovoltaïques
l'histoire du compteur linky est pas une
affaire toussaint tout simple qui est de
réserves que nous avons en terme de
l'utilisation des données personnelles
est là dessus par exemple nous
travaillons avec grdf par rapport au
compteur gaz qui s'appelle gaspard qui
n'a pas du tout le même fonctionnement
et qui est un compteur intelligent et
qui permet justement d'utiliser les mix
énergétique nous avons aussi travaillé
sur la nature en ville avec un
déploiement d'arbres fruitiers de
comestibles en ville nous avons
également travaillé sur les cantines
scolaires avec du bio dans les cantines
plus de 50% aujourd'hui et sur le
dernier marché avec du des contenants
bio compostables tous ces éléments là
nous les avançons et nous allons
continuer de les déployer sur le
prochain mandat parce que c'est
essentiel de transformer notre commune
par rapport à la transition écologique
sur notre action face aux changements
climatiques et notre protection pour
pouvoir intégrer le changement
climatique on aura par exemple des
travaux encore
sur les les économies d'énergie sur nos
bâtiments sur les énergies renouvelables
aussi et puis au niveau de la
restauration scolaire nous allons
travailler avec notamment saint rémy les
chevreuse par rapport à de la
restauration locale
vous êtes à deux secondes près à égalité
du temps de parole et il nous reste un
peu moins de sept minutes d'émission se
consacrer donc à à magny les hameaux
débats du premier tour avec 2 des listes
qui sont engagées que vous suivez sur
notre antenne également sur radio
sensations parlons fiscalité également
je vous propose de vous écouter
dans ce domaine chacun lionel lindeman
qu'elle ce quel regard vous portez sur
la fiscalité quelles sont vos
propositions concrètes
si on veut une minute vous pouvez
aborder ce sujet là deux minutes maximum
que nous ayons le temps les uns les
autres de répondre et ensuite d'aborder
d'autres sujets d'accords donc une
minute sur la fiscalité bon il ya un
constat tout simple vous étiez engagé en
2014 à la modération fiscale et un ans
après vous avez augmenté les taux
communaux de plus de plus de 10% alors
vous allez dire que ça n'est pas votre
faute que c'est l'état et ainsi de suite
le souci c'est qu'il ya beaucoup de
collectivités
qui ont vu qu'ils n'ont pas fait ce
choix qui n'ont pas fait ce choix là qui
ont préféré trouver des faits soit et
beaucoup qu'ils l'ont fait encore plus
haut si oui voilà d'accord mais ce qui
s'était engagé à la modération fiscale
lors des élections précédentes
enfin je trouve toujours étonnant de
vous engager sur quelque chose et puis
de faire autre chose après vous faites
souvent des beaux discours sur le
populisme sur la montée du populisme
mais qu'est ce qui cause le populisme
c'est se présenter aux élections faire
des engagements s'engager faire des
engagements très forts sur s'engager
enfin la fiscalité c'est quand même un
contrat trop si l'assèchement des
finances locales
et c'est peut-être l'évolution aussi des
compétences et le transfert des
compétences vers les collectivités qui
cause des problèmes au niveau local oui
d'action allez-y sauf que je répète
d'autres collectivités
d'autres mairies n'ont pas fait ce choix
là et je trouve ça c'est vraiment très
révélateur c'est vous parce qu'en fait
vous avez fait ce choix là est donc
aujourd'hui encore à chaque fois qu'il
est question de fiscalité de finance à
manier vous vous nous ramenez sur cette
question de la baisse des financements
mais cette baisse des financements elle
a été décidée par quelqu'un que vous
avez soutenu à l'époque françois
hollande et elle n'a été décidée que par
lui cette baisse des dotations des
collectivités
elle s'est arrêtée lorsque françois
hollande n'a plus été président de la
république on est trois ans a lancé marc
était juste la sensuelle manière
beaucoup plus sournoise et je vous
donnerai un exemple tout à l'heure
continuez les dotations aux
collectivités sont de 25 ans était de 27
milliards en 2010 at-elle sont toujours
au même niveau donc il n'y a pas eu de
baisse des dotations depuis et il ya des
écrêtements qui se font de manière
brillante juste pour nous à passer à 1
800 vionnet leader
vos critiques faire il faut envoyer
votre proposition aujourd'hui si vous
êtes élu vous ferez cette pause fiscale
ou par exemple vous voulez lire hors de
question de continuer à augmenter les
impôts on peut tout à fait il ya tout à
fait il ya énormément de marge à manille
pour ne pas avoir besoin d'augmenter les
impôts à chaque à chaque mandat et sur
ce sujet on va laisser répondre pertes
renvoyant justement puisque vous avez un
petit peu d'avancé du coupé retrouvions
sur la fiscalité vos réponses et puis
éventuellement des propositions pour le
prochain mandat
c'est facile quand on n'est pas en
responsabilité d'être démagogique dans
ce domaine là la fiscalité c'est un pot
commun au niveau de l'ensemble du
fonctionnement des services de la
commune et pour répondre aux besoins des
habitants
et là dessus il est faut aujourd'hui de
dire que l'assèchement des finances
locales ne continue pas un exemple très
claire sur ces deux dernières années
avec ce qu'on appelle l'écrêtement ce
que je disais tout à l'heure qui est
fait par l'état qui considère que les
habitants à magny les hameaux ne paient
pas assez d'impôts par rapport à leur
potentiel fiscal et aujourd'hui nous
avons chaque année de la part de l'êta à
décréter mans de 100 à 180 milles euros
qui se fait sur nos finances ça voudrait
dire que l'état aujourd'hui souhaite que
nous augmentons les impôts est
aujourd'hui l'état
je vous laisse regarder qui s'est donc
voilà on est face à tout ça aujourd'hui
il y a un certain nombre
d'interrogations de la part de toutes
les collectivités par rapport à
l'évolution sur la taxe d'habitation et
qui pose un certain nombre de questions
aussi sur finalement s'ils payent le
service public au niveau local c'est des
questions qui sont totalement légitime
aujourd'hui de notre côté oui nous
cherchons cette modération fiscale nous
la cherchons tous les jours par rapport
à des efforts drastiques de gestion par
rapport à des recherches de financement
et par rapport à un élément qui est
important sur lequel nous travaillons
avec l'agglomération qui est la zone
d'activités du parc du mérite et sur
laquelle il faut que nous puissions
avancer pour un pôle économique qui
apportera aussi un potentiel fiscal pour
la commune c'est des éléments qui sont
essentielles pour pouvoir poursuivre
rendu que nous avons nécessaire de
service public aux habitants et très
bien vous êtes à 9 minutes 50 à peu près
tous les deux les temps qui se sont
affichés à l'antenne neuf minutes 54
pour l'une des lignes de man 9 minutes
cinquante et une pour être précis pour
bertrand guillon nous avions prévu
également d'aborder la démocratie locale
au cours de ce débat nous arrivons déjà
à la fin de cette demi-heure le temps
passait toujours très très vite je vous
propose de passer à vos conclusions vous
ayez le temps d'aborder la thématique de
votre choix de revenir sur le débat
éventuellement d'aborder la question de
la démocratie locale que nous avions pas
encore abordé nous av ons a débuté avec
vous bertrand guillon nous allons donc
débuté pour la conclusion avec lionel
lindemann vous avez une minute trente à
peu près pour conclure d'accord
donc concernant j'aimerais juste
répondre rapidement at il retenu 30 jeux
se prendra rapidement
je signale simplement que j'ai regardé
ses des chiffres totalement officiel sur
20 ans les dépenses de personnel à magny
les hameaux ont doublé par exemple si on
fait la comparaison avec des transferts
en effet les 6-11 une association qui
était ma ni loi ziri sa femme notamment
oui c'est ça aussi oui mais c'est les
français mais l'obligation héliose et
c'est en régie aujourd'hui nîmes est
temps de conclure les uns les autres
allez-y brièvement et brad limites et
bien sûr je vous laisse répondre m mais
lionel in de match vous invite à
vraiment à conclure vous parler d'un
transfert qui est de 300000 euros
là le doublement ses 4 millions d'euros
donc c'est l'exemple que vous citez
c'est juste un tout petit détail
regardez l'on surnommé génère des causes
et les regarder vers manille lors qu'il
en soit si on compare avec les autres
collectivités de même taille
les l'augmentation sur 20 ans était
autour de 10%
donc le doublement à manille 10%
regarder à saint-quentin-en-yvelines
aussi dans le cadre d'une paix cicr dans
le cadre d'une intercommunalité comme
une ville où elles ont regardé où se
situe malgré un mot en termes de charges
de personnel si vous voulez qu'il n'y a
pas de personnel il n'ya pas les
services si vous voulez je constate
simplement qu'en 20 ans à exaucer
thématique une minute juste pour
conclure deux minutes
une nuit les spots votre ampli une
minute au plur donc nous n'avons pas
parlé malheureusement du logement on le
fera durant durant la campagne
donc nous nous considérons vraiment
qu'on est au bout d'un système qui est
là depuis depuis 20-30 ans notre commune
n'a pas connu d'alternance
depuis une vingtaine d'années quand on
sait comme c'est comme ça on a
l'impression et c'est ce que monsieur
avion illustre on a l'impression que
tout ce qu'on fait est parfait que toute
critique qui n'est pas légitime que
c'est démagogique propos qui a été tenue
tout à l'heure je n'ai pas tenu de
propos démagogiques j'ai simplement
ramené monsieur rovio à ses promesses
électorales
voilà donc nous en ce qui nous concerne
nous considérons qu'il faut une nouvelle
équipe à manier des hameaux pour sortir
de ce système avec une alliance
historique avec l'extrême gauche
il faut sortir de ça parce que ça n'est
pas représentatif de la réalité de la
commune de manière et je vous laisse
vous arrêter là vous avez une minute
trente pour conclure à présent bertrand
la gestion d'une commune et la
responsabilité d'une commune c'est pas
quelques semaines trouvé six ans et
monsieur lienemann qui expliquent ils
est sont apolitiques sur leurs listes
etc vient de faire la démonstration que
pas du tout en fait ils souhaitent tout
simplement un climat un clivage qui est
partisan
esseulé constaté d'ailleurs lorsque vous
étiez venu me rencontrer
où vous nous aviez fait un certain
nombre de propositions qui était tout
simplement partisane
aujourd'hui notre diversité des équipes
permet d'avancer sur un certain nombre
de points alors oui il y a des points
sur lesquels on avance moins vite que ce
que nous voudrions faire je l'expliquais
tout à l'heure c'est le cas sur le
marché c'est le cas aussi sur les
transports parce qu'il y ait un certain
nombre d'acteurs qui interviennent
dedans il y à d'autres éléments sur
lesquels on avance ça a été le cas sur
la solidarité c'est dommage qu'on n'ait
pas pu en parler là puisque l'accès aux
services publics pour tout le monde sur
le palm qui est le passeport loisirs
manie quoi pour permettre à tous les
enfants de la commune de pouvoir avoir
une activité s'insérer dans une dans la
vie associative je l'évoquais tout à
l'heure sur la transition écologique
mais sur le vivre ensemble également
pour permettre à l'ensemble des
habitants de participer à la vie de la
commune un certain nombre de structures
ont été mises en place et des ateliers
citoyens sont mis sur tous les projets
de la commune là-dessus et c'est une
règle d'or que nous aurons sur sur le
prochain mandat
tous ces éléments là je propose de les
continuer avec humilité et avec
sincérité
en dehors des clivages partisans nous
avons des valeurs que nous défendons et
qu'il sera important de défendre sur les
prochaines années mais nous proposons
d'agir avec tous les habitants
merci à vous d'avoir participé à ce
débat les temps par qui s'affiche il ya
deux secondes d'écart
vous avez joué le jeu merci à chacun
bertrand ou lyon lionel lindemann qui se
présentent sur cette ville de manille et
les hameaux merci de nous avoir suivi
également sur radio sensations je
rappelle que sur magna mot une manie les
hameaux une troisième liste cherche à se
constituer également autour de dominique
gratin d'ici au dépôt des candidatures
en préfecture ce sera le 27 février à
bientôt sur tv soixante dix huit pour un
nouveau débat dans le cadre de ces
municipales 2020
[Musique]